sept conseillers municipaux ne
paraissent pas tout à fait nécessaire
pour un tout petit village comme ça
néanmoins ça permet d'avoir plus de
répartition c'est-à-dire que chaque
famille peut avoir un membre au conseil
municipal
et ça permet une cohésion du village
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus franche est
réel
[Musique]
je suis brigitte chevreau merde là bâti
des fonds je suis à la fin de mon
deuxième mandat d'abattis de fond est un
tout petit village c'est un des plus
petits de du département la seule
activité qu'il ya sept un élevage de
garder un élevage de chèvres il y en a
plus beaucoup
il ya quelques vaches et un taureau
alors le maire d'un petit village comme
l'a baptisé forme mais évidemment pas ne
fait pas de politique bien entendu nous
sommes juste au service des habitants
pour essayer de leur apporter le maximum
de commodité donc l'essentiel c'est la
surveillance des réseaux d'eau
d'électricité
j'évaluerai ça à peu près une semaine
par mois mais de manière un peu
irrégulière ça peut être une semaine
complète où ça peut être plusieurs
week-ends par exemple
[Musique]
il
pour la prochaine élection dont deux la
semaine prochaine il ya dix candidats 12
électeurs dix candidats pour sept postes
à pourvoir
honnêtement non la campagne non on se
connaît tous très bien on est quasiment
d'accord pour refaire un conseil à peu
près comme nous étions jusque sur les
deux précédents mandats
donc il n'y a pas nécessité de faire de
faire une campagne et d'ailleurs vous
pouvez voir il n'y a pas de panneaux
d'affichage alors les fois précédentes
je crois que c'était 90 % il ya une
personne qui n'a pas dû voter et la
totalité des votants mais 2d m'a donné
sa voix c'est très rapide ça peut être
content de comptes des votes ça doit
prendre valu un quart d'heure vingt
minutes à peu près
on
oh
[Musique]
je viens là bas qui défend depuis 40 45
ans il a changé il y a quelques années
on était vraiment une équipe
on était un peu nombreux mais bon
maintenant il y un peu la vie du village
il très réduite
je pense que dans quelques années ça ne
sera plus que des résidences secondaires
très certainement
peut-être que je me trompe peut-être que
les enfants les petits enfants de ceux
qui sont résidents permanents maintenant
viendront habiter ici un jour j'en suis
pas certaine franchement
[Musique]
alors être candidat au conseil municipal
il n'y a pas trop de difficultés être
mère un petit peu plus un peu plus je
pense que là il ya personne qui veut
prendre la place c'est pour ça que je
vais continuer alors que bon j'aurais
peut-être arrêter si si il y avait eu un
autre candidat
mais là je vais continuer
[Musique]